okay welcome back it is time for one of
my favorite segments tinker taylor
shoulder pad yep
okay now this is fashion tips that
anyone can use and if you've been
staring at your closet thinking i have
nothing to wear i need new clothes think
again
because you can turn one closet staple
into so many fabulous looks and here to
show us how it's done is my fashion
partner in crime and true crew member
sandra roberts russia
i love these segments with usana because
you are my style icon please but thank
you very much i will take all
compliments i
you just i mean please you're so
experienced in beauty and fashion you
are the person who sort of leads the way
but your personal style i have fun with
it i think that's what it's about right
and it's about play time so we're gonna
take
one piece of clothing and show three
different executions of it
i love this approach it's like a kit
it's a kit exactly capsule kit it's
about being a minimalist but then making
yourself a maximalist out of using
minimal pieces and something can be day
to night or paired with different things
but you're going to literally visually
represent it so we don't have to imagine
it we've got amazing women who are going
to represent this
triple threat
of a turtleneck sweater okay and
why do you think that this is such a
classic
you know it's such a classic because it
can be super versatile i think it has
the ability to transform any look and i
think a common misconception is that you
have to buy so much stuff you have to
like keep stuffing your wardrobe fill
with the new trends hop on every new
thing out there and it's not necessary
you can actually do it with one key
piece that transforms looks into very
many different vibes as you're going to
see today on our triplets so
we have triplets ariana athena and
andrea here
first up
who'd have thought the turtleneck could
be sexy but it can and who'd really we i
don't think there's something that we
think about putting a slip dress over a
turtleneck but here we have it and she
is ready for a bar a date night a
restaurant um but i love the vibe with
the turtleneck keep it tight is the key
tip here you don't want something that's
baggy
underneath a dress i love the little
slit up the side the high booty a
fabulous bag and you are ready to order
your drink at that bar my lady i'm ready
ariana how do you feel
this is perfect because it's super glam
which is like my favorite thing ever but
it's very comfortable and also i have
all of these pieces in my wardrobe
already like the statement bag
turtleneck slip dress and some cute
little thigh high boots so i could
absolutely recreate this going home
right now today
thank you ariana so
[Applause]
outfit much this time we're kicking it
professional style with a work outfit
athena come on out
[Applause]
ready to take on the boardroom in this
who is not going to listen to this
turtleneck talk i mean it's so
good and if you if you weren't listening
to that you're going to give them that
stirrup pant
can i talk about stuart pence they're
all the rage against the rage i
full circle and it's about a lux like
and you could do a stirrup you could do
something with a slit front but a
tighter pant is definitely where we're
at i love it because you keep this
streamlined silhouette with the
turtleneck there but then you have the
boxy blazer that means business with a
red lip and everyone's going to listen
to every single thing that you say
athena how do you feel i feel really
chic trendy like young and i feel like
it's something i could throw on to go
into a meeting or just like around town
right so it's perfect it's fresh right
cool and everybody has an oversized
blazer and leggings with a turtleneck i
covet that outfit yeah i love the tone
of the bag too it's adding another
texture to it but it's not a bright pop
of color it's very
neutral and complementary yeah i can
lend it to you
but it also
makes me look at the pop of lip even
more right because it's not taking away
from that zanna you've done it again all
right let's see our third and final look
we're keeping it casual with andrea
come on out
[Applause]
this is exactly how i want to dress tell
me about every detail of this so the
detail so a turtleneck does not have to
be stuffy a turtleneck can be super
casual and it can take you into this
like cool girl world i love the vibe
with the big baggy jeans
a puffer jacket which is so accessible
so affordable and super on trend right
yes and very practical very on trend
right now really eyelash like everyone's
walking red carpets and puffers that's
how trendy they are i mean and this one
is fantastic super super affordable i
love it with the turtleneck underneath
because it keeps it's more streamlined
because you are wearing something quite
big
so you've got this like lovely
streamlined and then the little sparkle
on the top okay andrea how do you feel
you know i
i would wear this i'm all about the
baggy pants and the beanies on a regular
day so i could have picked this out
myself well this to me is the mood board
i need
to diversify
uh my turtleneck portfolio
so
and then look at your executions
well of course i had to try too but i
just like with a pop of color over the
top just you know i mean it's literally
another sweater over a sweater which
again is not something you maybe try and
do but as you and i know drew it's all
about giving yourself a little bit of
play time to throw together some looks
that you wouldn't usually do instead of
just going out and shopping more and
more and more you are giving me like
jailhouse rock meets like working girl
and i'm loving it your references are
brilliant i will take it i will take it
i'll bring the references
[Applause]
thank you thank you ariana athena and
andre you look so beautiful i was so
excited to do this with you
you really paint the picture you're all
so beautiful individually and you're
teaching us something right now and
looking so beautiful while doing so
thank you
actually works out really great for us
because our styles are so different
so like we this is like exactly what we
do at our house we share we'll share
like a basic top like this turtleneck
and then we'll wear it completely
different i love how you do the fan
thing as well then we got a little bit
more tomboy a little bit more cash it's
fantastic yeah that's us well thank you
so much ladies all right for santa's top
three closet staples everyone should
have go to our website at the
drewbarmershow.com
to learn more we'll be right back i'm
going on there right now
[Music]